The joe rogan experience.
Give me that shit.
Did you uh,
did you check out my,
um,
special bombing episode that I earned?
No,
you told me about it.
We were talking about it before the podcast.
We,
it's funny where I'll almost three hours then we were going to,
we really mention it or two hours in.
Um,
what the fuck happened?
You were up in Winnipeg as a Winnipeg.
I was um,
doing this club that I've done many times called rumors.
It's the old club.
It's a good club and it was a Saturday night and instead of like regular comedy
club crowd,
it happened to be like private events.
People like a group of 80 was doing their corporate party,
you know what I mean?
So it wasn't like,
it wasn't individuals buying one and two tickets,
which was a giant group,
giant groups.
There was like three groups.
One was like 81 was 60.
So you don't like,
it's more like you're doing a corporate,
like you're doing a private event,
you know,
and I talk,
I break it down if you,
if you want to listen to,
it's episode one 72 of your mom's house and I play the audio from this thing
falling off the rails.
And I mean it is like,
there was a lady who worked at the club,
she's been there 20 years and she told me,
she goes,
I've never seen shit like that.
Even close to that before what happened?
It was,
I mean I think it's like a,
a combination of things happening to them.
They fall apart that way.
Basically.
I went up there,
I had one guy in the front row who I fucking,
you know,
when he'd just hate somebody and you fixate on them because like this one guy
who was like kinda mumbling,
talking,
tagging my,
everything I saw no.
He's like,
yeah,
I bet you'd like that.
And you're like,
what?
What did you just say?
One of those guys who I fucking absolutely lost my shit.
I didn't lose my shit on them,
but I kind of tried to straighten them out.
And then there was one of the groups,
one of the groups of like 50 50 60 people was like being super loud and like the
first like really talking about when I went to talk to them,
they were kind of like dis like kind of shitty about it.
And the thing is like,
it's different when you,
when you do a regular show and you,
let's say you go after somebody or you go after a table,
you're just working on five people,
maybe write a group that like,
but then everybody else in that room has nothing to do with them.
Right.
In this case it was more like mob mentality where when I was like,
hey,
go fuck yourself.
Then the group is like talking to us.
Not you're not,
you're not just talking to them.
You're talking to my group of 80 so then it was like,
no,
fuck you like,
but in in unison there's all of them and then it just went.
Then I tried to put it back on the rails,
which I was like,
I'm sure I can,
I've done this a thousand times.
Let me put this back together.
Fuck you man.
Like it was like,
dude,
they were booing in unison for like 1520 minutes.
The 80 people at this point,
it was more than their groups.
So it was probably 200 people doing that.
All my God.
So is their group and then other groups chimed in and Saria Boeing.
You two unrelated groups?
Yes.
Wow.
It was pretty crazy.
And then they're like,
bring back the,
I had a black feature act to like bring back the Black Guy,
like screaming that screaming it man.
And it went and I,
here's the thing,
I resigned to the fact that it was so crazy.
It was less emotional.
I talk about this on that episode.
Then your standard bombing,
you're bombing an irregular bond where it's just not going your way and you
start to sweat and you're like,
man,
this fucking sucks.
Shoeing Dick's up here.
But like,
and that and that,
like emotionally affects you.
This was different in that I felt like their response to me was so outrageous.
Like I felt like it was unwarranted.
How upset they were that it affected me less.
Like I was just standing up there.
I was like,
all right guys,
here we are ready for some more jokes as they're booing me,
you know,
like not as,
I wasn't as flustered as I've been during a reg.
Real bomb.
Yes.
So you were just dealing with a giant group of Conc yes.
A school of cons.
Yes.
Swimming through your pond.
Yeah,
exactly.
Why did the club do something about that?
That's,
that's the only part I bikes I take responsibility,
I of that I tried to make it clear on that,
on that episode that like I'd take responsibility for yelling at a guy,
for insulting people.
Like I'm saying,
I put it on myself that I made things go downhill.
The club takes responsibility for kind of not really policing and they like the
one part is I tried to,
I told a guy that he had to go.
I was like,
you have to go,
you're gone.
See you later.
And you know,
I've done that before.
Sometimes you have to do that.
You're out of here,
man.
Right.
And then they were like,
the club came and taught and they're like,
just give him another chance.
He's going to be good now.
When I was like,
I've already thrown them out.
Like there's no,
we're not negotiating now.
Right.
So the club asked to keep the guy there.
Yes.
So that they do that.
I don't know.
But they,
they now realize that that was fucked up.
Like I've talked to them and they were like,
that was,
that was all some people you can give a second chance.
I've,
I've most likely,
most of the time I've asked clubs to leave people alone.
They're okay.
They're just not do that again.
And he'll say that.
I'm like,
yeah,
you can't yell shit out.
Just too,
too confusing.
I've done that a bunch of times.
Like he's okay.
Right.
But this time,
the difference was this time I was saying,
get them out of him out.
What was he saying to you?
Well,
this is going on.
He was,
it was the fucking,
he was the Mumbler the the tower like,
so we had our first interaction,
we had another interaction,
I think the third I said something to him,
I was like,
what the fuck did you say?
I forget exactly what he said.
And then I was like,
oh you're a tough guy.
And he's like,
do you want to step outside and find out?
And I was like,
you can go outside cause you're out of here.
You're done.
Get out of my fucking show.
It's my show.
You're Outta here.
And they were like,
what?
And His table.
He goes,
we all go and go,
great and have a great night.
Get the fuck Outta here.
I don't need you here.
That's when the crowd was the problem.
We felt like we were discussing what happened.
I was talking about it with the club.
The guy is that a lot of people in that room didn't hear what he was saying.
He thought I was just attacking a guy for no reason.
Right.
That makes sense.
But I still,
I take,
I was an asshole that night.
That's,
you know,
the guy was clearly,
he was instigating it.
Yeah.
He was a fucking cunt.
He was a real concept of guy and I didn't like him at all.
And you know,
I don't think that like,
like I always say,
I don't have to be like pleasing to the different,
like I,
you know,
I'm there doing comedy.
You came to see my standup if you want,
if you're not liking it,
that's cool.
But if you tried to take over the room,
no.
Well it's not just taking over the room.
It's interfering.
Yeah.
It's interfacing,
interfering with the performance and it's,
there's hundreds of other people that have to deal with the fact that you have
to deal with this guy.
It just,
it's,
it's all in how to do it and not lose your cool and when you lose your cool.
Yeah.
So it's a fucking bad scene.
It's a terrible feeling too.
It's crazy.
And the audio is insane.
I mean,
you've probably not heard alarming like that.
Yeah,
it's a different,
it's not like a standard bombing.
I mean there's,
there's a lot of aggression from,
from the crowd on it.
And how does it end?
Well,
the best part and the only,
cause I also was bummed at myself for not,
I was like,
I,
you know,
Yo,
you always look at moments where you're like,
I wish I had said something funny or here,
right.
This was an opportunity to be funny.
I really,
you know,
so I was like,
a lot of it,
I was like,
ah,
you know,
I really,
they won.
Like they defeated me.
I was like,
but the only funny thing I'd said was like,
at one point the manager came up to this stage and he was like,
are you okay?
Like he was checking,
he came on stage and was like,
cause it was so crazy.
And then he's like,
Yo,
all right.
I was like,
yeah.
He's like,
do you want to keep you long?
I was like,
yeah.
And he's like,
okay.
So he leaves and they're like,
yeah,
that's right.
Get the f because they think he's telling me get off stage.
And I go,
I go,
he asked me if you guys wanted me to bring back the other guy.
And they go,
yeah,
I think they scream yes.
And I go,
I told him,
you guys want more of me so here I am for more jumps.
And they're like,
so they go so crazy at that point.
He's a Canadians too.
Yeah,
they go fuck with the nicest people ever.
But in the very end,
the lady who was running the,
one of the private events that night,
like she brought her group there,
she was in tears,
she was crying and they brought her on stage.
They were like,
she wants to say something.
And I was like,
oh,
because my plan was just right.
Stay here the entire time,
no matter what.
Talk about recipes that you want to try it like dog days them.
Yeah,
right.
She gets up there and she's like,
please,
I know I've done fundraisers here.
Like I really wanted this to be a good night.
And I see like how like she's a right way affected by this.
Please give him the respect of like some just your,
your time and like,
just let him talk and they're like,
it's too fucking late for that fuck.
Like they're going crazy.
Oh,
right.
And I see her like,
just like she's defeated.
It's like someone was beating her up.
Right.
You know?
And I was like,
oh my God,
I go,
you know what?
This is 35 minutes in,
right to what's supposed to be like a 50,
55 minute set,
so there's 20 minutes to go.
I was like,
you know what?
Um,
I don't,
I want her to have a fun night.
She like,
she like,
it affected me because she was so,
I was like,
I'll tell you what,
because you're a nice lady and blah,
blah,
blah.
I go,
I'll bring back the black guy.
So I brought the black guy back on stage and they went fucking,
it was like I said,
Ladies and Gentlemen,
Chris rock out.
Yeah.
He went crazy.
I was like,
dude,
it's all you.
And he was like,
oh my God,
I can't believe people actually like black people here.
Like he was so excited.
Does he have any more material?
Yeah,
yeah.
He had me,
he had his name.
I should give him credit to his name is,
uh,
tricks.
That's his whole name.
Yes.
Like silly rabbit.
Trix are for kids.
Yeah.
Wow.
But I mean like,
you know,
he goes,
you guys can pull that off.
You can push it like that.
Office Tri Double X.
I think so that was on what episode of Your Mom's house?
One 72.
All right.
It's um,
it's a,
it's a fun episode to listen to.
You did for putting that audio up.
That takes balls.
Yeah.
I wanted to,
man.
I was trying to,
yeah,
there's tricks.
He did a good job,
man.
I totally give him credit.
Cool.
Yeah.
That's an interesting story.
I'm going to listen to that podcast.
Okay.